there's a word a subject a a topic of
interest that I think people don't know
as much about as they should okay it's
all about
Isotopes you remember the periodic table
of elements that mysterious chart of
boxes that hung in the front of the room
all year in chemistry class yes there's
a sequence of elements beginning with
hydrogen and they get sort of heavier
and heavier heavier right and they each
have a number so hydrogen is number one
helium is number two so we're not just
numbering them that is the count of
protons in their nucleus right who's got
12 protons who's got six protons there
is an element and only one element that
has that many protons in the nucleus
there you go some famous ones carbon has
six protons six protons oxygen has eight
protons I left one out nitrogen has
seven protons okay
uranium has 92 protons okay when the
periodic table of elements was being
discovered there were gaps so you knew
exactly what to look for if you were
missing an element look for the one with
39 protons go go back to the lab it's
like a a a chemical Lego
set just you just put it in a slot click
clicks right in and move on and so we
have found 92 quote natural elements in
the universe 1 through 92 hydrogen right
on up through uranium and we have
another how many up to 118 now going
Beyond uranium we made those in the
laboratory you think you can play God
sir is that so you're just making
elements now the answer is frankly yes
yeah there you go so these are the
protons and they're immutable what I
mean is if you take away a proton it's
no longer that element it's the other
element right if you add a proton it's
now a different element wait a minute
protons all have the same charge H they
all have positive charge so what does it
mean to cram them into the nucleus of an
atom if left to their own devices they
would what oh man they you know it's
they'd be the Real Housewives of New
Jersey that's what that's what theyd be
get out of get out what
you f the
table so what holds them together well
there's a whole other force of nature
called the strong force fundamental
force of nature fundamental force of
Nature and it's propagated by a particle
called the gluon right an apply named I
might add and this happens by the
presence of neutrons
in the nucleus right so neutrons Tamp
down the resistive forces and they act
as a sort of a glue for the nucleus
unless you Martha Stewart Adam in which
case it's a hot glue
on that was terrible they all can't be
winners like you said exactly you know
I'm going say Martha should not have
gone to prison for that I should have so
hydrogen in its native state only has
one proton right doesn't need a neutron
right to hold anything together so
native hydrogen is just one proton and
then one electron on the outer side by
the way in a red blooded atom they have
as many electrons as as protons so
they're electrically neutral right okay
so uranium would have how many electrons
as many as it has neutrons no no as many
as it has protons mean protons protons
how many is that um I don't know you
remember I said it 92 92 exactly so so
matter is generally neutral for this
reason okay hydrogen is Happy let's go
to helium helium has two protons right
its native state has two neutrons okay
suppose I force
hydrogen to accept a neutron and I cram
it in there okay I can do that now I
have what's called heavy hydrogen heavy
hydrogen it has a whole word that we
have for it's called d
oh you might have heard the word dyum
dutel what is what does dyum do you can
make a water molecule out of dyum H2O if
one of those hydrogens is a dyum then
it's
dho is that heavy water that's heavy
water heavy water you might have heard
of heavy water yeah you can add two
neutrons to it okay we have a word for
that obese
water it's called tridium tritium point
is when you do this to an
atom adding neutrons or possibly
subtracting neutrons if it has stuff it
won't miss you made an
isotope aha so dyum and tridium are
isotopes of hydrogen of hydrogen let's
go to carbon carbon has six protons in
the nucleus right so red blooded carbon
would have how many neutrons uh six six
and it'll have six elect carbon bada
bing okay oh wait a minute I can add two
neutrons to it ooh so now it has six
protons and now eight neutrons add those
two numbers to get what do you get 14 14
carbon 14 carbon 14 as in Carbon 14
dating yes yes you know someone should
make a carbon 14 app the dating app
that'd be that'd be kind of cool that'd
be kind of cool so that's a isotope of
carbon all right it turns out carbon 12
is stable 12 is six protons six neutrons
it's stable right you add two neutrons
it's not stable right it will decay in a
halflife in a halflife and the halflife
of carbon 14 if I remember correctly
it's around 5,000 years which means
after that amount of time half of the
carbon 14 is no longer there right it
has decayed and then you wait another
5,700 years half is gone again right you
wait another 5,7 it's half a half of a
half is an eighth right so you keep
doing this and you know what it does it
gives you access to dates across all of
recent human history from when we were
in caves up through recorded history
right on up back through thousand years
ago 500 years ago so it's very useful
for dating life on Earth some carbon
that's in your body is carbon 14 so how
how do we end up with the carbon 14 in
our bodies so carbon in nature add
carbon 13 in there too so have carbon 12
stable carbon 13 stable there's not much
of that carbon 14 unstable unstable okay
so in the
environment carbon 14 would normally
just disappear except there are sources
of carbon 14 from cosmic rays from space
space Rays space space rise space r we
got space raise okay you know what else
boosted carbon 14 levels what the
nuclear tests that went on in the 1950s
and 60s ah so here's what happens when
you are alive you uptake that native
amount of carbon 12 13 and 14 into your
body okay and it stays at that level
okay until you die because then you stop
ingesting more carbon there's carbon in
all foods you eat basically right or
food that has any nutritional value has
carbon in it okay the moment you die
you're no longer refreshing the carbon
and the carbon 14 then decays and then
that's when we can figure out the timing
correct the nuclear tests have
interfered with some of the Baseline
measurements of what's going on in in
our environment uh so you have to sort
of get get the nuclear tables together
with the tables of nature in order to
figure out what the starting levels were
for life forms that were exposed to it
we've actually put the finger on the
scale the thumb on the on the scale
thumb on the scale with the with the
nuclear test yeah with the nuclear test
anyhow I was just you know chewing the
fat here with Isotopes I love it and you
know they're fun other part of what's
going on on the periodic table of
elements yes and one other thing
hydrogen has one proton and helium
remember has has two and helium in its
native state has a total of four
nucleons two protons two neutrons right
and it's stable okay it turns out
there's that's that's called helium four
because it's got four particles in its
nucleus two protons two neutrons helium
four if you take away one of the
neutrons right guess what you have um
helium 3
yes helium 3 helium 3 now here's what's
cool about helium 3 helium 3 is one of
the particles ejected by the sun and it
gets embedded into the lunar surface we
might have talked about this in another
show so helium 3 is yet another isotope
but now that's one with one fewer
neutrons instead of more neutrons than
what was there before nice all right
this's been another explainer from Star
Talk Chuck always good to have you
always a pleasure Neel the grass Tyson
keep looking
[Applause]
up
[Music]
on